boom I'm the last one in number six the
unexpected so this is not warzone land
this is the first time I'm doing this I
think I'm stream at least my dad did it
one other time anyhow crown stars 3 3 5
21 is a round-robin 960 rated tournament
only six players how many rounds are
there hang on how many rounds five
rounds
okay let's click out of that stuff let's
get to the game oh okay
three minutes to figure stuff out these
guys don't have to move what else
pod push in the center this night can't
be too happy or actually let me do this
first what's unprotected nothing pawn
push here because this pond wants to
move and I want to be able to take it so
let's do this
I'm glad I got into this one okay now
what bishop sittin here night here pawn
push pawn pushy or pawn push here now
there is no pawn push here maybe c4
could be played though I want my pieces
to be behind my pawns and I think with
this move I start to become better I
think I'm gonna have a beefy Center real
soon right here if something isn't done
fast and I don't know if anything could
be done fast oh I think there's some
serious trouble now for white this
bishop is gonna have the door slammed on
it it's officially slammed and now
follow up moves Knight coming into this
juicy square that pot has gone far
enough
I do not want to deal with that pot
let's do this and then
it's getting my bishops out a bit right
here why not capture like this open up
this diagonal where would my knight like
to be maybe I shouldn't have allowed is
there light square bishop gonna get out
of control maybe I could Castle kingside
actually on my first move I could have
Castle kingside
two minutes Oh little scary here about a
knight right here Knight right here how
about there's nothing tricky is there I
have both of these covered and that is
definitely scary okay guess what I need
to Castle queenside my king is gonna be
whisked right away Here I am gonna fly
over to the Queen side or am I let me
stop me maybe didn't I'm gonna try to
deter this move I may be king here is
better I don't know maybe King here is
best I think it is actually I don't want
to cancel Oh get out of pins it's play
here gotta go quick a minute twenty
let's do this pawn pushes there there
are my rook you might want to just give
that up or not let's come over here it's
safer isn't it why did I go there of all
places I'm not quite sure clock
situation I can maybe take on this
square a bunch of times or I could take
right here cuz my queen is that has
pressure on this night Oh Queen takes
Knight takes pawn one minute 32 now it's
coming with check Oh Knight takes here
no I come back okay with check I'm
getting some material and there's
probably a queen check or no I take here
with the check okay the position is
crumbling I have two pawns this should
be good
okay let's just play here play solid
backup box the Night Out pawn push
probably coming up playback here let's
get this in all I'm dropping upon I'm on
the road come on the road come on the
rook okay they missed it I missed that
one and as a follow up there's a fork
right here incoming
oh it's crumbling let's guard this their
pieces are constrained all the pieces
are constrained do not lose this ever
you do do not do lose this it's okay to
give that guy up it's okay okay
everything's under control
King position get my age pawn going
let's keep going
let's keep going pawn push Forks just so
this bishop doesn't go anywhere I don't
want him going anywhere
King here bishop here and then a check
against their king
don't have any time right here nothing
to do I should have just gone there
Aragon there
okay just push next push again and okay
that's gonna be it there's nothing
tricky no tricks mate too close to it
mate next oh the bishop good block okay
I just take it though okay they resigned
back to tournament
okay again this is a round-robin if
you're unfamiliar with that there's
nothing like it's not like the war zone
you don't get paired up right away with
an opponent you have to wait for
everybody to finish the games do not
move on rounds do map
do not move on until everybody is
finished and everybody seems to be
finished here if you're wondering the
average rating for this 960 is 2189 okay
limb a minute Knights in the corner
tough spots what's unprotected both
these guys right here which ones are
accessible I don't know what's this
Knight headed for maybe this could I go
after that guy I don't know what do I
wanna do is my first move right here
right here I like this move I think
let's try this okay gotta go quick three
minutes is not a lot of time for a
chess960 game okay
pawn in the Senate what's stopping me
nothing
both my bishops could come out right now
my queen can maybe come here I want my
knight here real soon probably developed
this knife he's stupid in the corner
dark squares okay could I get this pawn
I'm gonna do this get some space here
I'm not sure where I want a castle
how about pawn push Knight here now
that's a possibility I'm gonna try it
and if he ever gets kicked around with
this move okay let's do this and I want
to support my knight um I think it's
coming together here let me do well my
night can't be threatened just yet let
me do this
I want my knight to maybe get here
that's a little bit scary it's a little
bit scary without a doubt well what do
you do if you're scared okay well
they're gonna get my darks for a bishop
if they really want it they're getting
it but now they're not because I'm
carding this and this this Knight is a
giant pain and they're putting a lot of
pressure on me I can't push this night
away he's a pain he's a big pain let's
try this I don't want that rope to get
active
fortunately I'm watching over this pawn
this I can't get rid this Knight I think
I need the King sight castle it's very
scary very very scary I can't do this
because of Queen here it's ugly
okay I have this square covered with my
knight but I cannot rely upon this the
Bishop of play here I could take this
though and then get my queen up in my
dark square Bishop up maybe this could
be an issue right here we're about even
with time let me do this hopefully the
knight recaptures but I think it's best
if they don't get my Queen up
on this I'm on this with my knife for a
second I thought the Queen could come
here and what a pain well I'm not gonna
be cake castle Queen I should castle a
queen side maybe what am i doing what am
i doing
let's try that I have to Castle
queenside fortunately I'm watching out
the Queen doesn't have anything on these
diagonals let's try this
I still can't castle it cuz of Queen
here it's a giant pain I have to get rid
of this night I think if I could get rid
that night things will be okay how about
night here just sack up on just get rid
of that night I want to get rid of him
1 minute 20 now I think is the time to
do it I'm gonna do it now because I get
this maybe I could get this pond this
pond could fall but hopefully I could
stir up some trouble over here somehow
can i stir up some trouble now clean
there no I'm getting this pond and I'm
defending the pun let me back up I guess
looks are gonna be doubled real soon
and oh that okay I need to get this
Bishop out of here
I have checks may be available around
the Queen and the bishop let's take here
let's take that night my bishops stupid
over here pigs look up and over
okay let's try this
Oh interesting
looks a little awkward I'm gonna try it
though we are knotted up I'm on the
clock here this is a really really tight
game gotta watch for a c7 and not fall
for me I'll scream if that happens
don't let that happen Queens the Queen's
coming off I think I want to keep my
rook around let's try this keep pressure
on this I want to run to e7 with my king
can I make that happen that's wrong
that's where I'm heading
I really don't want to move this pawn
because let's do this I don't want this
pawn to get pushing 30 seconds
let's come over here is it safe just
couldn't be a check I could get to check
back though I get that e4 pawn let's
stop this from rook nonsense maybe I
stopped the rook nonsense let's play
here I'm on the rook let's back up
defend stuff here give a check with my
queen sneaky stuff right here where's
that mate pawn takes I go to where okay
where the sneaky moves block with the
Queen you know you want to block don't
fall for me sneaky um give a check give
a check they don't have any time they're
down on time
okay fortunately the clock is on my side
here do not fall for me
don't fall for me
okay their downtime oh man
back to tournament Wow
these are tough oh I don't have a
breather this is feeling like a war zone
okay apparently I was the last game to
finish okay what is going on with this
arrangement game three round three two
four two so far what some protected I'm
not sure I think this is a good start
follow up with the night f3
actually I'm gonna do this play here I'd
like to get LightSquared Bishop Soph
pushing up here and I have a serious
space advantage and I think I'm already
better because this is this is very
annoying the LightSquared bishop is off
the board I would love to get a knight
right here if the LightSquared Bishop
SAR off I'm gonna do this even though I
have a space advantage I want to make
sure the LightSquared Bishop Sargon more
development pawn up right here supported
knight in coming to this square right
here but not so fast more development
I'm gonna do it my queen she wasn't
doing anything in the corner follow up
with this and then Knight here looking
for Forks and I believe this move is
good or no it's not good really it's
post up this Knight
I want a queenside castle I'd need only
get my darts for Bishop out I'm okay if
the knight place to either one of these
two squares to get my darks for Bishop
off the board and apparently it's gonna
be chased away real soon okay let's come
back I have control over this I'm gonna
let it sit it's just Castle Knight takes
I take care I want my rook on e 1 my
queen is in a good spot I want to maybe
get here and then to this let's do this
first watch over this square I'd like to
get in g4 g5 is that gonna happen though
not so sure let's do this let's do this
stop the night I should have done that I
move sooner Knight here is available I
think this is not the right idea I don't
want this night to be able to move
hitting my queen and this pawn I'm a
probably should do this I shot probably
should have been doing that for a while
if the a file opens up I'll try to get
over here really quick but there might
be
going to h3 hitting that let's do this
because I as soon as I move my knight
I'm on this night so a night move that
I'm threatening here I don't know if I
really want to do this okay let's go the
Queen could it maybe somehow get trapped
if I could defend this pawn not so sure
maybe c3 just to be extra cautious
there's a lot of tension right here and
here we go it's blowing up right now and
hopefully at the end of it I have enough
support for it I'm gonna take with the
pond I think doing it would like that is
correct I really want to get this Knight
out of here this is the second time that
there's a knight my position it's really
scary it's really scary so if I go with
this oh this is winning for me they end
up in a pin at the end of it just this
and then I bring my queen back and
that's a pin they can't get out of it I
think I have it it's pin I just take
this bishop on the next move and that's
TKO is it that got really intense look
at all the defeat different pieces that
were focused on e5 if there's a summary
to that game its 'if I've that's it so
now tricky stuff right around the corner
forks discovered attacks against the
rook has a follow up Queen to e4 I think
his lights out if the King goes here or
here or here Queen right here is uh as
close to just that being it right there
actually if King here I have Queen check
followed by a fork or something there's
a lot that out black has to be sorting
out here and this is a deadly fork
that's TKO
okay back to tournament back to
tournament okay I apparently was the
only one or the first one finished let's
see what's going on elsewhere how am I
do
in the standings I won my last one so
I'm three for three blitz star is two
for two let's see how his game is
currently going blitz star Blitz star
has just resigned whoo
okay he just resigned okay so I think I
have soul leads so far after three
rounds we're still waiting for
round four and here we go
round four is this the fourth black that
I have in a row here what's unprotected
okay I think I like this as a starter
maybe shut down this Bishop with this
move here knight c6 as well maybe pawn
push in the center I'm gonna I'm gonna
play in the center I could get my Bishop
out and if I do this I end up losing a
pawn takes takes takes the Queen's come
off and the bishop gets the pond so what
do you do instead you get more
development in how about this my bishop
is stupid in the corner so it's not
gonna be stupid maybe I should have done
something else though okay this is a
little scary let's come back here is
there anything else I don't know maybe
night out I'm thinking about c5 but I
just don't know how actually that could
actually work let's get that Bishop out
there I don't want to deal with that
Bishop I want to push it around with
this excuse me sorry about that okay so
so far so even here timewise I'm gonna
try that if it comes back I'll consider
Bishop here if Bishop takes I develop
and whoa are they thinking that their
queen is um was developed are watching
over that I think I watch it watch over
this square and things are really good
my dark square bishop my knight wants to
be right here boom boom boom where
there's a nice laid upon there exist
posts for your pieces however with the
position close to opening up
I want to get being a spot record castle
let's get this in right now and let's
chase this night away maybe a little bit
they're gonna probably do that if I
could kick this night away I think I
think I'll be a little bit happier with
things if my night is no longer round I
could think the night before to d3 that
would be a great spot to get to we're
not having that let me take here and
then okay the Knights taking I kicked
that night around a little bit
how about here and then here like I said
or not what I do this or I get my Queen
out yeah let me get my queen I want to
watch over this my bishops boxing out
there Knight Mike we can maybe come here
they could still castle in which
direction Oh Jericho is Queen side and
this seems really good I'm gonna go for
it
d3 or take this pond but I think we're
gonna be seeing a break happen right
yeah there it is okay let me oh this is
protected with the Queen I don't even
have that
let's take like this first and wow this
is scary
I'm gonna do this just to keep my king
side a bit safer and maybe I could get
Queen h4 and if Queen takes I play here
let's see if that's gonna help out I
want rook c8 Queen Queen here ideas
taking on this square rip to c8 maybe
even rook up and over that's a good move
and they're hitting my bishop as well
that was good
I'd like to maybe get this move in this
is trouble this is big trouble the
knight coming here I think is gonna be
strong I'm in trouble I need to castle
or I should I don't even know if that's
gonna be helpful I got to come back a
very very minor time edge my knight is
probably a bit annoying if okay oh man
this is this is a problem
I got to defend like this this cannot be
good no way I'm in trouble
Queen needs to come here or something
rook here King here get off of this file
yeah that's scary that's very scary oh
that's that's a nice move right there I
think this is needed anything can happen
Oh a knight right here I think is a
winner I have to do this wow really
messy really messy let's do this is this
working
it could have connected past pawns
this is this is tough really really
tough here think I want to be here this
is a really big issue a really big issue
fortunately I'm watching over these
squares right here Oh what am I missing
I'm on there Queen what am I missing
I have to take what am I missing Oh what
am I missing
I'm on their queen what am I missing
today you miscalculate they
miscalculated I think do I have this
right I just want to take this pawn and
I have it this square oh they got that
oh man take this do I have it time
situation ah it's so nervous I'm so
nervous right now no don't get active
rook defend hello let's come over here
what's the story defend
oh I'm just dropping that I just dropped
a rook I just dropped a rook they missed
it no no no no no no no over here over
here over here over here clock situation
time time time time they're in check
time burners
they probably expect that they have my
rook don't take my rook I got the Queen
move I'm not moving they're down my
dream oh sorry if I got loud please
don't listen with headphones oh man I
was holding my breath again
oh my stomach is clenched right now told
her my breath in like I felt like I was
just doing like a hundred situps right
there
okay overtake it waiting for around five
this is the fifth and final against
blitz start they want to try I'm going
to try and get five four five deep
breath you could do it you could do it
okay refocus I'm going a little loopy
right here hang on okay this is not
protected so that means this is
unprotected I want to take here and kill
a knight okay they're defending that
this is a problem maybe maybe I could
get this in I need more development I
got to watch out for this though if the
knight moves I could get this guy I want
to be cautious of that let's get a pawn
in the center I want to watch out for
this move okay pawn in the center let's
go pawn in the center I have a good
centered pawn push here a space
advantage then I can't do anything just
yet my bishop out and get my
LightSquared Bishop out okay space
advantage I guess this is the move I
need to be a bit more concerned with
let's pin this Knight I might want to
just take them give up my light square
bishop okay that's the direction they're
going in okay I could go queenside
castle I'm gonna come all the way back
because I want to stop this Knight move
queenside castle to defend against that
night I have a lot of control over this
square let's do this King side castle is
still pretty good too let's get my queen
up I think Queens Kings side castle is
best anoles just mouse slipped out okay
we're gonna have a little bit of a trade
I'll recapture with my queen and I'm on
that eight a six pawn they might miss
that and they did miss it
I recapture with my bishop I got up
I snagged that pond right there sneaky
now I could rely upon what square let's
come here again okay I'm on this I want
to stop I want to watch out for this
move and I should probably prevent it so
let's prevent it
stop that pond from going any further
Bishop here is probably good
what's this Knight going to do if this
pawn can't move or this pawn can't move
he's stuck in the corner if this pawn
can't move and if this pawn doesn't move
then he's dead if I keep these pawns
right there then there's not much that
they can do right here this pawn is
pinned I have Knight takes pawn
available bishop here maybe just
exchange rooks get my King towards the
center how about this move and if here I
go here and give up I give up upon just
so I could get this one and have a
two-to-one majority on the other side of
the board
so right here I'm on this night but the
brook could be defending but I guess I
get activity with my bishop bishop pair
and this pawn is weak I want to hit it
next let's do this first I have a check
available my knight is the last piece I
need to get working everything else is
working let's support my Center if I
maintain this pawn I'm controlling this
light square bishop let's get active
right here let me give a check first and
then another check unavoidable and then
I could dodge this Knight takes Bishop
move or is there something more direct
could I take the knight I'm not gonna go
for it I'm on this I'm on the rook and
the King has to be very careful very
very careful check check Bishop check is
that made or something that might be
close to me if I take care of on the
rook and the knight
what's the calculation around the
calculation here actually I just want a
side step this I want to hang on to my
light square bishop I don't want to give
it up and I want to stay on this
diagonal so avoid that exchange I'm on
this pond again and this Knight I don't
know that there's a good defense here
we're even with time should I just take
here and then take the knight and then
go after this pawn is there something
better how about
how about this I want to get this pond
up here night here I back my bishop all
the way up bishop air this night is very
very strong I want to push here and then
get my knight to f6 that's the plan
let's go forward with it right here
incoming f6 I could probably pre move
that now my bishops are seeing a lot of
the position I could kick this night
away for they missed it they might
resign that's game I'm not going to take
it yet I want to get everything out of
this position first before taking that
rook they resigned yes I'll take it
that's the fifth round I was four out of
four that's five out of five coming up
very cool chess960 games that are still
going on there's one more let's see how
it finishes up with the final standings
crazy nights in the center and what else
okay white is on this rook why could
have taken that rook white looks dead oh
why isn't that taken how black is just
playing around trying to give white some
hope yeah that must be what it is
watch out for stay on it yeah that's
definitely what's going on here and
thirty seconds each for these these guys
yeah this is the guy that should have
beaten me in that time scramble what is
holding my breath and doing situps how
many sacks are you gonna have on this
silliness in action behemoth watch it
end up being stalemate is it gonna be
stalemate we're gonna have more sacks on
this square black is having fun saying
you know what you are not gonna beat me
no way I am going fast
watch out first tell me watch out for
stalemate this is ending soon six
minutes there you have six minutes six
seconds
now the king has to come all the way
over to deliver me that was the only way
to win it apparently and now the bishop
gives me finally first-place confetti as
soon as it finishes I'm gonna take it
and I got some crowns
this is granola City right here that's
code for you get some I mean crowns
translate into cash but actually they
don't anymore anyhow alright games